this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much for the introduction
and thank you for having me i always i'm
always very nervous when i speak at
cornell this is i think it's called
imposter syndrome
this is when the others find out that
you're not worth it
and and um or you feel at least it's
that way
so i hope i can show you something i'm
actually wanna take a little bit of a
risky torque some of you may have seen
at least
parts of the first part that i'm talking
about today
but i want you to take part in a
process that i went through while
thinking about plant responses
to any kinds of environmental stresses
and i emphasize plant responses here not
right away start with plant resistance
which is what we are actually studying
in my lab so induced responses that are
functioning as resistance
eventually against insect herbivores
but i would rather take that much more
neutral step in viewing all
plant responses as neutral to begin with
and
you will see why i'm sort of emphasizing
that in the beginning already
and before i actually start i want to
show you the people that are involved in
most of what we are doing
what i'm talking about today and and
these are
um two postdocs in my lab who both left
this summer was really bad stuart
campbell and reicholichke
um oh no that's the third poster who
left who's also involved in the work
that i'm showing today akanesuki
and so there's some places open now in
the lab and then there are the
a grad student kim morel and an
undergrad student amy erickson
who i will show data today
and in fact the undergrad students here
in the picture so there's
two of them only and one was back here
in the building they all
just last year wrote each one a paper
on their honors thesis that was um are
now in review so it was really
impressive to have this group of
undergrad students in the lab so when i
talk about induced plant responses
then i'm talking about metabolic changes
of the plant and
in the most basic sense you can envision
so the
so we not only talk about changes in
secondary metabolite production but also
bob turgeon unfortunately is not here he
wrote me
an email this morning that he wanted to
come but he knows very well that also
primary metabolism is changing
dramatically in response to any kinds of
environmental stresses more or less
depending on the plant species
more or less depending on plant genotype
we will see some of that
that later so what happens when an
insect is actually feeding
very strongly depends on the
environmental condition in which the
plant is growing on the plant species
that you're looking at and on the insect
herbivore and this is probably the most
important
or if you want the attacker in general
right and i'm saying insect turbo
because it can be as
fine-tuned as in this particular case
this
is a crisis mallet beetle or larvae of a
chrysler mallet beetle called triropta
vergato is feeding on goldenrods who are
now nicely flowering outside
and they feed on on these golden rods
and golden rats
you can based on in golden ruts you can
based on the secondary metabolite
production
tell two different chrysomelet beetle
species apart
on the plant and it's very consistent
across different genotypes so that means
even though
there may be large genotypic differences
in the resistance of those plants to
the different species the response that
the plants have
after they are attacked by these
herbivores go all in the same direction
does that make sense i tell you that in
the beginning i'll come back to that a
little bit later
so now people have speculated about
induced
or the function of induced responses a
lot and as i told you induced resistance
was the one thing that came up and
everybody is talking about
plants become more resistant after they
are attacked and change their metabolism
and this is true
in many cases but by far not in all
cases so we also have cases of induced
susceptibility
so the metabolism changes to the benefit
of the herbivore attacking the plant
and there may be no changes at all which
you know people who work here on
pathogens and herbivores
may be familiar with there's a lot of
experiments that seem not to work right
but they
are simply nothing happens to the plant
seemingly nothing happens
and one thing that induced responses of
plants also mediate is something and i
also want to kind of take
a more neutral stem to that is called
indirect resistance traits and in this
particular case it's the
um the metabolic change in the plants
provide
some sort of information that allow
another organisms for example an
organism of the third trophic level a
predator
to use that information and find that
their prey in this case it's a
merit bug that is the herbivore in this
case
and and kill that so in this particular
example it's about tobacco plant
and that i was working on with ian
baldwin already at max plunge and we
continued here a little bit
um in this case the damage by the
herbivores is inducing a very specific
volatile emission i mean species for
herbivore species specific volatile
emission
those volatiles can be detected by those
predacious bugs they come in kill the
herbivore and save the plant in this
particular case
um it's actually very efficient so they
can reduce
or the plant's ability so we did that
with genetically modified plants that
were not able to emit volatiles
and or not able to respond to damage per
se actually both both of these things we
tried
but in all of those cases a plant that
is not
responding to the damage and therefore
is not providing information to the
environment
um and in this particular case not
emitting volatiles
has a 90 percent higher damage rate than
a plant that can do that
right so it's a traumatic effect of
dramatic indirect effect through
the third trophic level interactions so
people came up with
a lot of theories of why plants change
their
metabolic phenotype in response to
damage right so why do you have this
kind of
stress response and in the beginning in
fact it
was totally focused on induced
resistance
right because people found that if you
put an insect herbivore on the plant
that has been damaged already
they usually perform worse
on these plants in comparison to a plant
that was not damaged before
right and so the first ones were for
example rhodes here
who wrote about an evolutionary
hypothesis for why plants do that and he
came up with the idea
well it's simply a part of what we call
the optimal defense
theory so optimal defense theory
says that plants should allocate their
resources
so that they affect the benefit they
gain from investing into defense
does not compromise their reproductive
success
right and so what that means is
when an insect when a plant is
responding to an insect
or a pathogen or whatever is changing
its phenotype
it is based on this hypothesis
investing in investing in the into
costly defenses
only when it's needed in the case of an
actual herbivore attack
right and otherwise if there's no
herbivore or no pathogen they wouldn't
invest into those defenses this is
optimal defense theory
and induced resistance was seen
in the early days as a cost-saving
strategy
that is functioning on the plant
phenotypes within a
lifetime of a plant right so the plant
can allocate resources as needed
you can read about that in in the carbon
involvement book and also there's a nice
review and quarterly review of biology
when nancy stem
very recently that sort of summarizes
all the defense hypotheses
so this is overall um induced inducible
resistance as a cost saving strategy
there were two very nice
papers one that derived actually from
work that ian baldwin still did as an
as a graduate student here at cornell
and one that now our own
anarch agrawal did and they published it
in the same year both in
one in science one in nature um
where they compared
plants that are constitutively investing
into those resources so they
treated plants so that it would always
be induced
compared to plants that were never
induced compared to plants that only had
induced resistance when needed
and they found that there is a high cost
when you
have the plant constitutively induced
right
this was great this drove an entire
field
but there is a problem with that right
so you're comparing
two things two metabolic states of the
plant that involve both as i mentioned
in the beginning
primary and secondary metabolism it is
not that metabolic change is not in fact
only the upregulation of costly defense
metabolites
there's a lot compounds that are
downregulated in response to damage
for those of you who do some hplc or
gcms whatever they're
in many cases almost as many compounds
down regulated as upregulated
right so you cannot make that cost
argument at all cases
and secondly it's not that clear how
costly these compounds really are
and people have tried to analyze that
and to calculate it through and whatever
but it seems to be all within the
tolerance
range that the plant has available and
resources and to allocate into some
defenses right
so plants for plants it's not that
costly to produce these compounds
presumably
right and so there were other hypotheses
that people came up with then
so the other one was the distribution of
damage within the plant
so when you have a modular pump most
plans are actually modular
and you have one branch here and one
branch here if there's damage on this
branch is inducing resistance forces the
herbivore to move over
the idea behind that is if you have one
branch
and all leaves of that branch are
stripped down
the seed production on this branch will
be much lower
than if you had that same amount of
damage distributed across the entire
plant
because then the damage on each branch
may be within the tolerance range that
the plant has
to compensate for the amount of damage
that it receives there was a very very
good one but there's only very few
studies done on that
um and the this one actually
that was the original one was a model
study so it's a
just a mathematical model and this one
is the
only one that actually thoroughly tests
it
then the third one i already talked
about um
the attraction of predators and
parasitoids to the plant requires a
metabolic change because otherwise
there's no information
right so if the the herbivores are
presumably under selection to be
stealth feeders so not being seen by
anyone by any predator by any parasitoid
so you will see a lot of adaptations in
insect herbivores
if they are not themselves very toxic
right in which case they're aposomatic
they will smell exactly like the plant
or they will look exactly like the plant
or they will be underneath the leaf
or you know these kinds of things they
will be not seen
and therefore there's a benefit from the
plant's perspective to
attract predators in through a larger
signal potentially
and this could be induced of a volatile
emission but that only works
if the metabolism of the plant changes
with herbivory because otherwise there's
no information right
in that so if a plant for example would
constitutively emit volatiles
the predators would soon figure out
there is no prey associated with that
particular
queue that's coming off the plant and
then there is one
almost forgotten so-called moving target
hypothesis that
was brought up by um recarbon on his
then
um postdoc and um
this comes from military right military
strategy kind of thing so if you
move around a lot you are a much worse
target than if you are standing in place
right and the military people use that
and his argument was
this is exactly what plants do so
there's not a per safe fitness benefit
of producing the compounds only when
needed it's simply the metabolic change
that is adaptive so it's not the
increased production of defensive
metabolites or resistance mediating
metabolites
it is simply the metabolic change so the
plant becomes something different for an
insect
and it makes sense to a certain extent
because
all insects in particular those that
feed on larval stages on plants have
this initial feeding bouts
and so they have their first feedings
very little and then they wait for a
relatively long period of time before
they continue to feed
and this is when they ready their
detoxification enzymes and stuff like
that they optimize
their digestion to that exact plant
genotype
right and if the plant is in that time
frame changing its metabolism it becomes
something different
so it becomes that moving target that
the insects have a hard time to follow
in which case the simple change in
metabolism over time
is adapted from the plants perspective
because it will reduce the fitness of
the herbivore on the plant
now we wanted to study all of this and i
kind of as i mentioned
um we'll give you some information that
some of you may have seen already
from our work on wild tomatoes in peru
because we
wanted to study these kinds of effects
on wild species
and that started an entirely new kind of
thinking
and i wanted to have you be part in that
kind of thinking
so we went to peru this is how it looks
like
and most of the tomatoes so what is it
12 of the 14 so far described tomato
species
grow on the pacific slope of the andes
and this is in general a habitat that
looks like this so it's a
relatively dry habitat all the wild
tomatoes
in comparison to other plant species are
extremely trout resistant
and they are usually the plants that are
green and flowering when everything else
is yellow like in this picture
and they continuously flower throughout
the entire year and i have green leaves
throughout the entire year
um the plant species that i want to
focus on
in this talk is one that is one of the
most widely distributed wild tomato
species called solano perovianum
um and just to mention there's you know
some studies that we want to initiate on
this one
this plant grows in the valley where we
are working um
from 500 meters above sea level up to
3800 meters above sea level
continuous population of course
everything changes along that gradient
right
um we are worried that actually the
plant species may change too but
this is not yet figured out um but this
plant is attacked by a large number or
relatively large and for a surprisingly
large diversity of insect herbivores
and originally the idea was to study in
very detail and this was physiological
detail
the plant's specific responses to those
different herbivores
and it turned out interestingly that
the wild tomatoes that we study are not
specific at all
so in other words it doesn't quite
matter which herbivore is feeding on the
plant the plant will generally do the
same thing to an extent
in this case that we now wonder
whether or not this is adaptive in this
particular case for a particular reason
so we don't know that as this one one
future study that we want to do
the other things that we had figured out
we see a couple of
induced metabolic changes that include
secondary metabolite production
um anti-digestive protein production
like protein as inhibitors and stuff
like that
and we see an induced resistance to
herbivores
normally not to all what's important
though from my talk is that
the diversity of herbivores feeding on
the plant is only matched by the
on the leaves is only matched by the
diversity of organisms that feed on the
flowers
um and so we have a also surprisingly
high diversity of
bees feeding on those plants and the
special thing is here um
you may know that actually all solanum
flowers have these undercones where
um the pollen sacs actually open to the
inside and so
the bees or the pollinators have to be
specialized to get any pollen out of
those plants
what they do they hook onto the plant
vibrate their wings and it comes out
so this is vipre tile or bus pollination
and it needs some behavioral
specialization on the side of the beast
that's why it's surprising that we had
such a high diversity of bees doing that
and we in fact established in this study
um the first encounter of elected bees
which are very small bees
to bus pollinate flowers so they were
not known to bust
at all the entire group of electives and
they do it here
now the thing was that when we started
the work with the wild tomatoes
what we figured out very quickly was we
have absolutely no idea about the
ecology of wild tomatoes
so nothing was known other than where
the plants grow and even that was
um old data charlie rick's data pretty
much
from his collections in in peru
and a lot of those sites that he cited
on on that are still cited on the on the
website um are now paved over
so you can't find the plants there
anymore so we had it took us quite a
while to actually find the plants
but then there was in the literature was
nothing known about ecology
not nothing about the herbivores that
are naturally associated with those
plants nothing about the pollinators
and so we had to do some very general
ecological service and among them was
one survey
where we compared the proportion of
leaves damage as a very crude measure of
damage
so this could be even in that category
here you could have
only 10 percent leaf tissue removal but
every single leaf
received a little hole right so every
damage
on a leaf was counted as a yes on that
leaf
and so you get a percentage of leaves
damaged
as a crude measure of damage and on the
other hand i just told you about the
pollination marks
we use the proportion of flowers with
pollination marks
as a measure for pollinator traction
right and so those pollination marks are
these brown marks which are a result of
a polyphenol oxidase reaction
when the bees hold onto when they bust
pollinate right they have these claws
and they hook
onto those anthrocones and then very
tightly hold on and then vibrate their
wings
so that this entire thing is vibrating
and the pollen shoots out on the bottom
and then they collect the pollen from
their belly right
and this actually this mark is species
specific if you if you train your eye
you actually know which bee species has
done that and it occurs
within five minutes after a pollination
event happened right
and it is in fact the pollination event
we don't know how successful is it may
still be different between the different
bee species but it's definitely
a pollination event because it's
normally the bee's ballet that's a
that's a
touching um the stigma down here
and then pollen is deposited
so this was our measure and we saw this
very interesting pattern so the more
damage you have on the plant
from herbivores on leaves right
the fewer flowers in those
inflorescences
have pollination marks suggesting that
there is
lower attraction of pollinators right
but this is just a correlation so those
two things may not be causally linked
and that's why we started a small study
that generated everything i'm telling
you today
um so we did an experiment where we
manipulated herbivory so we had plants
that were not damaged and then had a set
of
damaged and undamaged plants in this
particular case they were damaged by
flea beetles simply because they're
easier to collect and to control on the
plants
um and when you have a certain number of
beetles feeding on the plant and this is
actually less than 10
leaf tissue removed i emphasize that if
it becomes important later
you get a significant reduction up to 25
reduction
in this particular case in proportion of
flowers
um with pollination marks so
fewer pollinators are coming to the
flowers when they're damaged
you can simulate that when you apply
methyl gestamate so methyljasminate
is methyl easter of gismonic acid which
is a phytohormone that has been shown to
be crucial
um for the endogenous signaling
associated with mechanical damage
so if you silence for example we have
done that in other plant species
if you silence yoursmonic acid
production in a plant inducible gismonic
acid production plants are
not able to see a herbivore feeding
there will be no
induced change in response to that
damage
and this is where we were feeding so you
will still see a response to a pathogen
though right it's important
um so if you apply just simply methyl
gestimate meaning without any damage
this is just making the blood believe
that i don't like i'd like to say that
so you you simulate damage by just
providing the endogenous signal that
signals damage in the plant right
without any damage available and you get
the same a similar reduction
in pollinator attraction and that
translates in a traumatic reduction in
seed set
and as i said a twenty-five percent
reduction in z-tech so it has a fitness
effect
and this is actually in fact the largest
fitness effect we have ever seen coming
from an
herbivore and in this particular case is
simply mediated through the attraction
or non-attraction of a pollinator now
you could still argue
well maybe this reduction is simply due
to
the fact that leaf tissue is removed
and therefore there are less resources
available to put into seeds
right so it's maybe not has nothing to
do with pollinated attraction maybe in
the plants would still
even though we have fewer pollinators
coming they would still produce the same
number of seeds so it's not necessarily
the pollinators that cause this
reduction in seed set
it could be simply the amount of damage
but as i told you in the experiment we
used less than 10 percent damage
actually overall
but we wanted to make sure that this is
true so what we did we only used
methyljasminate
and then had open and hand pollination
so with methyl jasmine we already
exclude any damage
but yet methyl jasmine it was or
gismonic acid per se
was first identified as a growth
inhibitor right so we have to see that
so they may
just the signaling itself may reduce um
seed production
and here when you have open pollination
we get the same picture as we had before
right and this is now the number of
fruit seeds per fruit produced
but if you hand pollinate them and cover
them up
then you get even a slightly higher
production when you have adjustment here
so that shows that it's not due to
limited resource availability herbivore
damage it's 2-2 limitation
by pollinators and because that i call
that
herbivore-induced pollinator limitation
which is what that is now
we wanted to figure out why that is and
now mechanistically why why do the bees
actually avoid and so we look for
signals
of course there's two obvious ones one
is
maybe an optical hue that's changing if
you look at the flowers on the uv
um tomato flowers usually the
the petals well i should supposed to do
it here
but here's actually the picture is not
so so clear the petals are actually
reflecting uv
while the anthracone is strongly
absorbing a v so under uv this is all
shiny light and this is
black dark even though it's all yellow
to us
right so there could have been a change
in that that visual cue in response to
damage
especially when i tell you metabolism
changes dramatically
but it could be also the volatiles
coming out of this
right and this is how we trap volatiles
in the field so we develop this very low
cost system
on this end at least on the trapping
side is low cost and when you run it on
a gc it becomes
more costly um because we have far more
samples to run right so
this this method allows you to do up to
16 samples per pump so the more pumps we
can carry to more
car batteries we can carry into the
field the more samples we can take and
we are now we have some experiments they
go up to 120 samples per
experiment and what we do is we pull
ambient air through that chamber over
the plant
and this particular case obedient
fluorescence and onto
absorbent tubes and they could be in
this particular case it's charcoal
that's absorbing the organic compounds
and then you elude them down with
dichloromethane or hexane
and analyze them in a gcms
this is how that looks like in the field
this is right or my long-term postdoc in
lab
and it's pretty dangerous in some cases
because the plants
tend to grow on these landslides
yeah it could be dangerous never mind so
what do we find
blur your eyes and concentrate first on
the first two so these are
plants that were not damaged this is
just a normal
volatile emission from leaves not from
flowers this is from leaves
and this is a plant damaged by manduka
caterpillars so this is the tomato
tobacco hornworm actually used to be
called until
1964 this was the tomato hornworm
and then another species became a tomato
hormone and this became the tobacco
hornborn
um i just highlight here there's a
number of monoterpenes and a number of
sesquiterpenes that are dramatically
upregulated right
you just look here dramatically up in
response to damage and this is what you
see normally in tomatoes tomatoes very
smell very different when you damage
them within herbivore
now the interesting part was that now we
go down here if you compare
um leave a mission with flower emission
there are a number of compounds that are
only produced in the leaves
you may say it is not a surprise it was
a surprise to me because if i
put my nose on a tomato flower i don't
smell the difference between the flower
and the leaves
and it's probably because the leaves
already smell so terpenoid
that it blocks up everything that we can
taste but
but this is actually so there are a
number of compounds that are only
produced in the flowers but the biggest
surprise was that
there are a number of compounds that are
only produced in the flowers
and only in response to herbivore damage
on the leaves
so you get a specific metabolic change
in the floral metabolism
in response to herbivore damage which
provides a potential signal for the bees
to differentiate at least between
damaged and uh flowers on damaged and
undamaged plants
and so for that we had to and i have to
speed up a little bit um
we had to come up with an experiment and
i very briefly explained the experiment
and very quickly go into the result
because i want you to see the other
more evolutionary study and what we
could take advantage of is that these
tomato plants
are huge so they often have three meters
in diameter in the field
with a lot of branches and those
branches are
independent meaning that if you damage
one branch you can measure induced
and systemic induced resistance along
that entire branch
but it will not affect at least not
directly affect
a neighboring branch so you could have a
control branch and a damaged branch on
the same plant as the ideal kind of
comparison so if a paired comparison
then but what you can also do is
you can bring the inflorescences of both
together
so that what you can create is a
chimeric inflorescence
that has either the order of a damaged
plant or the order of a
undamaged plant or the combination of
the two
and then if you want to test whether or
not a visual cue is involved as well you
can cover up
one part of it so in this particular
case what that was was
in the back was the inflorescence on a
damaged branch
and outside is the visual cue of a
non-damaged branch
so the bees would be exposed to an
undamaged flower bouquet
but it smells like a damaged right and
then you need a lot of controls for that
and we had to do this because we
couldn't take the bees home and do
choice experiments in the lab so we had
to do it in the field
um but it actually worked surprisingly
good so we did that with actual damaged
plants and also the methyl jasmine
treated plants and this is the
the methyljasmine treated plants and
what you see here so these in this case
both influorescences are open but here
is a pair this is the full control
which has um the actual test in
fluorescence that we're looking at
as well as the one that's supposed to be
treated but in the control it's not
treated so this is just a double
inflorescence
of undamaged flowers in this particular
case
only this inflorescence is on a damaged
branch this is on an undamaged bonds and
they are combined but both of them are
down
already suggesting that the volatile
emission is probably important
now when you cover this one up then you
can only measure
pollination here right you still have
the same effect
so there seems to be no visual cue
involved it's all all factorial
right and then just to make that quick
so this is pretty much equivalent
to this result this is exactly this here
so we because we were wondering where is
the volatile emission coming from
so here it's the flowers only in here
then we put leaves on a damaged plant in
here
nothing different and we also put
methyljasmite only with the flowers
because we
you know methyl jasmine can be smelled
by by bees so it
could be detected by piece of methyl
jasmine could actually here be a problem
but it's not but it means that
the bees orient towards or away from
the specifically flower specific
and herbivore damage specific odors that
are
in those flowers here okay
now this entire thing started an entire
new large project in my lab
that was asking more evolutionary
questions
so if the chemistry the floral chemistry
is so strongly linked to the overall
plant metabolism
that is also changing in response to
herbivory
then there should be a very strong
interaction both ecologically and
evolutionary
between the selection by herbivores and
by pollinators on chemical traits of the
plant
right and it seems like we have this
negative selection
uh sorry they have this neck a very
negative effect
of um on pollination by herbivores that
this is
um kind of an antagonistic interaction
evolutionary
we would expect right so to
bring that together so i'm just um
concluding what what i just said
so here we're going to use changes in
plant metabolism include vegetative and
floral volatile emission
the pollinators use the volatile
emission to avoid flowers on damaged
plants
that comes with a fitness cost for the
plant and we don't know how long that
fitness cost goes we can discuss that
later
so because those are perennial plants
and we obviously have only a snapshot so
there's there's a little bit more to
that story but it could have that
negative effect
and i didn't talk about the
morphological changes in general the
flowers do not morphologically change
especially to the relatively small
amounts of damage that we have on the
plants
but what changes very consistently is
the length
of the pistol and so in tomatoes and
this nice work by steve tangslay in this
building
or in the other building was the other
building when he was still here
and they found that the pistol
elongation is something that happens at
anthesis and is pretty much
only the expansion of cells
right at that stage and this expansion
of the cells is seemingly inhibited
when you have damage on the plant which
results in the pistol being pulled back
or stays back actually i don't want to
say pulled back it's not pushed out
um the out of the under cone so it stays
in the other cone but this is another
kind of question and this is um the
hypotheses that they derive from that
they correlate correlated evolutionary
process between defensive and
reproductive strategy
and potentially habitat specific
outcomes of this process
now
at first it felt really difficult to
approach that from an evolutionary stage
but then there are grad students that
are over ambitious
and advisors like me that allow that
over ambition
so stuart campbell was in my lab and
what he did was
he took a total of 56
species of solanaceous plants
that were in groups of self-compatible
and self-incompatible so they were
different in their mating strategy
right self-compatible self-incompatible
and then he tested all of them for their
induced responses to herbivory
so that you have a measure for
constitutive resistance when you compare
the self-compatible self-income battle
within each group
and uh and also the induced resistance
of those
so the idea of that grouping is that we
have phylogenetically independent
replicates
or independent comparisons between a
self-compatible and a self-incompatible
species
and that actually includes in this
particular case
19 independent replicates
of the shift from self-incompatible to
self-compatible which we commonly have
in plants
but in solanaceous plants it is even
more pronounced
so in all the phylogenys that you see
from solanaceae plants there is no
suggestion
of a reversal of that thing so it always
goes phylogenetically from
self-incompatible to self-compatible and
not reverse
right meaning self-compatible is the
derived state
but that's important for later on so
what he did to these plans as i said
within each species with replication
he had a control that was undamaged a
planet was mechanically damaged and the
planet was damaged with manduka
he did all the chemistry for all of
those plants and then also
fed the plants back to manduka neonate
larvae
to measure resistance directly and this
is actually the novel part in this so we
standardize
all the resistance to the resistance to
manduka
right you can discuss whether or not
this is good because there may be other
species and
things like that but if you standardize
it
to the most resistant plant you can
pretty much
compare resistance across the entire
phylogeny
right and the reason why we did these
two
treatments was that you then have a
measure by comparing these two
of the specificity of the induced
resistance right is it specific to
manduka or is it just general
okay now how does that look like if you
just look at constitutive production
sorry of constitutive resistance and
meaning you only compare the controls
within each group and
and here there's uh so the
self-incompatible or in green and
self-compatible are in blue
and if you blur your eyes you'd actually
see that there is no pattern seemingly
no pattern
um and it turns out that there is though
a slight
increase if you can control for
phylogeny
so self-incompatible species in average
have a higher resistance than
self-compatible
this is something people had expected
but nobody has really had really looked
into it
so self-incompatible and average have
higher
constitutive resistance than
self-compatible this was kind of
expected
not necessarily that strong but it was
now if you blur your eyes here you see
that very strong shift
of the blue ones to the right and this
is reflecting that if you look at
inducibility
inducibility which is the magnitude of
change in resistance
after the plant was attacked by a
herbivore right after
resistance is induced then
self-compatible species have a
much stronger induction than
self-incompatible
and this was a big surprise i had never
expected that
so let that sink in a little bit
self-compatible species so
those who sometimes inbreed
right may or may not but sometimes in
breed
are stronger inducible than those that
never inbreed
now if you just look at the resistance
at the induced state right so you just
compare resistance
of damaged plants with each other
there's no difference
so that means that self-compatible
plants
compensate for their disadvantage in
constitutive resistance
by changing their metabolism in a in a
stronger way and now i got
already gave you a hint the metabolism
in fact is changing in a stronger way
right so it's only resistance in this
picture but the metabolism has changed
so we were asking
is there some pattern that we can see in
the metabolic secondary metabolite
production
that could explain that pattern and
sure we do and this was a big surprise
to me too
if you just look at this so these are
pairings that are actually in
in those comparisons so four independent
pairings
in the petunia genus and the cestron
genos and two in solano but there are
two different
clades within solanum independent clades
here the self-incompatible ones and here
the self-compatible ones what is the
difference
what do you think
do you see a difference in general just
blur your eyes a little bit
exactly so they have far more compounds
over here so there's no per se
difference in the amounts of compounds
if you just sum up all the compounds
there's no difference but if you look at
the diversity of compounds produced
self-incompatible species have always
almost
always more compounds than
self-compatible species
right now interestingly so this is the
picture actually
control for phylogeny it's highly highly
significant so this is only for phenolic
compounds but you can do that for
terpenoids too
and you see pretty much the same picture
so diversity of compound production is
higher in self-incompatible species
we think that heterozygosity is
affecting diversity of compound
production
so within each plant but also the
compounds available within populations
and that led to a hypothesis and that's
why i'm speeding up a little bit
that inducibility is generating diverse
phenotypes in time so what does that
mean
high diversity high compound diversity
is very strongly correlated
with resistance i will show you a
picture in a second it's and
in fact after we found that we went
through all of our data
diversity of compound production seems
to be the strongest correlated with
resistance
in comparison in particular to just
individual compounds
if you just come you know correlate
individual compounds with the resistance
you never get a strong correlation
as the diversity of compounds that may
give
self-incompatible species that advantage
so this is the outcrossing advantage
they have potentially
and that potentially leads to a
increased natural selection
and this is now our hypothesis we didn't
show that here um
increased natural selection on
self-compatible species
for stronger inducibility because the
stronger inducibility allows the plant
to change its phenotype and time
to diversify its phenotype in time
and that gives them the same advantage
as the high diversity compound
production
that the other species have the
self-incommerce species have
another thing that's that's correlated
with this is the specificity
remember i had the mechanical damage and
the caterpillar damage
if you plot the
resistance effect on caterpillar damaged
against those
of mechanical damage plants if you have
a strong correlation there which we have
here in the green line the
self-incompatible ones
then you have low um specificity
right so it's the same response if that
switches and becomes
not significant and you have a higher
specificity in the response and this is
true in the self-compatible species so
the self-competitive ones
induce stronger and induce more
specifically
right and then there is this nice
conservative induced
resistance that was always hypothesized
that there is a trade-off in fact so
people hypothesize there must be a
trade-off
between the expression of conservative
resistance and inducibility
that's true it looks like it right so
it's a negative correlation
and our data actually support that
hypothesis in that way but my argument
is that trade-off is not necessarily a
fitness type trade-off it is in fact
a reflection of two alternative
strategies
either having a high diversity of
compounds produced
and not having to induce resistance
or having a very low
because of the mating system they are in
having a low
compound diversity and therefore being
on the strong selection to induce very
strongly to diversify the phenotype in
time so this is the hypothesis that we
are now following up
um and do a lot of work on now and i
think i have to
to stop here simply um only five more
slides but i want to stop here to
allow for some more discussion um but in
conclusion what that means
first we have a very strong correlation
between the reproductive and the
defensive strategy so this was the
important point of this study
and this is a macroevolutionary
correlation in this particular case we
also have with work on
um native solan solanum karlinems we
showed that
there is in fact within a species a
similar correlation happening
um and so there is something to that
mating system and resistance
are strongly correlated and associated
but what this here is actually providing
is
in fact a new hypothesis for why
inducibility can be important
which is independent of the costs of
compound production entirely independent
right
it provides an alternative strategy for
a plant that has to live
or for plant populations that have to
live
with low compound diversity right
and with that i end here and hope we can
have some time for questions thank you
very much
have you been able to follow up with
other boards
no we haven't only within species and so
the solanum karli
nens example there we had different
herbivore species and it is in fact
um differently expressed in different
species
right so with different species if you
will so if you take and this is
purely because um
the response to certain herbivores is
stronger than to others to begin with
but also certain herbivores respond more
or less
to the changes and this is an important
ecological problem actually not a
problem for us actually an ecological
explanation problem kind of um because
what that means is
you would have to know what is in order
to argue there
may be natural selection on those traits
and on those
in this particular case on inducibility
right you have to know what the
dominating herbivore in the system is
that might actually
inflict um fitness costs that are high
enough to drive natural selection
to begin with and then that herbivore
has to do something to the plant that is
or the plant has to respond to that
herbivore in that particular way
we have a number of of different which i
don't didn't talk about today we have a
large project on goldenrods here too
and goldenrod has one of the most
diverse alphabet communities directly
associated with them that i know so
there's
in this area about 120 herbivore species
directly associated with goldenrod 80
of them are specialists and in those
cases you find everything so you find
induced susceptibility to one herbivore
um that for example that herbivore is
inducing susceptibility to itself so
they do better on the plants that they
themselves damaged
but induce resistance to everybody else
right
which suggests there might be some
manipulation of the inducibility so it
could be a cost of induction
um and then there is um herbivores that
induce resistance to themselves so
strongly that they have to move away
and things like that so there's any
variation of the theme so they
in the end it becomes the question which
one of those herbivores is driving the
evolution
right or is it all of them together
which is still a big question
in that field anyway um but it's a very
good question from edward spring
um
that's a wonderful question that's a
wonderful question so we did
um a number of studies with um ian
kaplan who is
now a duke um who
for his phd studies actually with us um
analyzed in in tobacco whether or not
induction through the roots and
induction through the leaves
it changed some effects above and below
ground so they seem and
there was a um a
meta-analysis associated with one of
those papers where we looked into
are below ground insects affect above
ground insects more than the other way
around
and it is actually that way so if you
have below ground herbivory there seem
to be stronger metabolic effects above
ground
and therefore stronger ecological
effects but the other way around is not
as strong
now the question is and this is still
kind of a weird thing in the field
is that simply because we have a harder
time measuring below ground
things that go on below ground or is it
a true
a true thing right and so
at this point i think
a number of people think that there is
something fundamentally different
between above and below ground
i actually don't think so um but
we are actually not yet there to say
something about it to make that
comparison
truly happen um and there is another
good example is goldenrod
um when we relieve golden rats from
natural selection by herbivores
the low ground chemistry goes up through
the roof
and in this particular case it's
supposedly an allelopathic compound that
we see go up
but that compound is not only
allelopathic it is actually a highly
cell toxic compound and a japanese group
looked at it and they kind of wanted to
do an kind of
how do you call it an ethno-botany kind
of approach to goldenrod
and they tested it on mammal cell tissue
cultures on
nematodes on bacteria and it kills
everything
right and uh and so the question is you
know
is there simply resources freedom this
is this is an evolutionary process so
it's natural selection but
it's different genotypes that do that in
those populations when you
we so what we did was we repeated that
experiment that dick rooted a very
famous experiment where he
had goldenrod populations right out here
um and
had plots that he sprayed with
insecticide for a number of years
and left the other open to ambient
herbivory
and it found huge effects on the
community so they were studying the
community interaction so they saw that
the diversity is dramatically dropping
when you take the herbivores out because
you
benefit the dominating plant species in
there which is solidartissima
so what we did was out of those plots we
took
samples and clonally reproduced them so
that we had
independent replicates of those and when
you compare them you see
they're completely different genotypes
right and that
are phenotypes too right so different
phenotypes that are there so they have
lower resistance when they're in the
spray plots
and even when you have them several
years now out of the out of the plots
already
and and they have this very interesting
dramatic dramatic increase in
illegopathic hormone production
and so there is definitely both
evolutionary and on an ecological
level a very strong interaction that we
and i agree with that
totally underestimate um
but it's not time to say whether or not
the mechanisms that mediate those
interactions are different below and
above ground
thank you this has been a production of
cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu